[MUSIC PLAYING]
Some days, it feels like
I'm constantly on the move,
commuting to work,
running to the shops,
finding that underground
performance art space
my friend wants to meet at.
I need all the help I can get.
With the Google
Maps SDK for iOS,
you can help your
users find their way.
I'm Jen Harrington, and
I'm going to show you how.
Take this situation,
for example,
of a couple of friends trying
to meet up before a show.
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Hey, I'm at the
cafe near the venue.
Want to come by?
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Where's that?
On the corner by my old place.
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Huh?
Um it's near that giant
tree, uh, opposite the bank.
Gah.
See how frustrating that was.
That's because describing
location and place in the world
is hard, but it
doesn't have to be.
Wouldn't it be great if he
could have just shown me
where he wants to
meet, instead of having
to describe it with
crazy landmarks
or precise geographic
coordinates.
Instead, this is how
it could have gone.
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Hey.
I'm here.
Come by.
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Oh, I think I know that place.
Is it-- Yup, I know
that storefront.
[TEXT MESSAGE ALERT]
Cool, I'm on my way.
What happened under the hood
is that the app used the place
picker, so my friend
could very quickly
specify the actual
business where he was.
Then it drew that place
clearly on a map for me
so I knew where to go.
I was able to dive in and
actually see the Streetview
imagery of the place he shared.
The Google Maps SDK for
iOS expands the vocabulary
available to your
users when referencing
places and locations.
Looking at another
example, I live in Sydney,
but my family's
all back in Canada.
When my mom came to visit,
she only had two days
and she wanted to see
as much as she could.
Thankfully, the Google Maps
APIs came to the rescue
and we used a transit app to
get her efficiently from place
to place.
All she had to do
was specify where
she wanted to go-- the
Opera House, the Harbor
Bridge, Coogee Beach, Then
she'd get a list of buses
next available and
walking directions
to the bus stops from
her current location.
And where could she best
see this information?
On a map, of course.
This is a great example of
connecting the API building
blocks together-- the
Places API Autocomplete
feature to get the information
on the destination,
the Directions API to
get the bus schedule
and the walking paths
to the bus stops,
and the Map CPI to
actually show the routes.
Note that the Directions API
is actually a web service.
It's being called by my server
and proxy to the client.
With all these great
features, you're
going to want to make
sure your app reaches
as many users as possible.
And you can trust the
Google Maps SDK for iOS
to scale with your user base.
Your millions of users are
going to live around the world
and speak many
different languages.
With Google's places
database covering
more than 100 million places
worldwide and every API being
tailored to suit the
languages of your users,
they will love you for
going Google on IOS.
So get started integrating
Google Maps into your apps.
Check out the documentation
and install the Google Maps SDK
Cocoapod.
Once you start using the
Google Maps SDK for iOS
and see how nicely
everything fits,
you won't be able to
imagine it any other way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]